Dr. Connors regarding our conversation on Monday about my labs and my thyroid numbers,
my thyroid doctor asked about maybe thyroid cancer possibly reoccurring. I want your thoughts
on that. Scary. Thank you. So that person's thyroid numbers, if I recall, they had
elevated TSH, over 100. So TSH is thyroid stimulated, horrible. That's created in the
in the two terry gland. They had depressed, depressed, reverse T3, and they had depressed T3,
and depressed T4, free T3, and free T4. Negative TPO antibodies, negative thyroid globular antibodies.
That is the picture-perfect diagnostic scenario of primary hypothyroidism. So it would be very
rare for a person with thyroid cancer to have any abnormalities in their thyroid numbers.
Either their T3, T4, typically thyroid cancer doesn't affect T3 and T4, but thyroid cancer
does not affect TSH. So when you have elevated TSH, depressed T3, free T3, depressed free T4,
negative under antibodies. That is a picture-perfect example of primary hypothyroidism.
There's always that one in a billion chance that it could be something else.
And to get, if you want to, rule it out, rule it out, get a scan an MRI of the thyroid gland,
and you could rule it out. Typically, if cancer of the thyroid gland was reoccurring,
you would see other palpatory findings as well. But if you want to be careful and rule it out,
I would not say those numbers are indicative of thyroid cancer returning based upon the numbers.
That's a mean that something might not be going on, but I wouldn't look at that to even cross my mind
that is an ominous sign of thyroid cancer. There's lots of
standard blood work and specific to an organ or something like that blood work that you could run
that gives you ominous signs. It's not diagnostic of anything, but an ominous sign kind of gives you
clues. So, for instance, some ominous signs in your complete metabolic panel would be
wow, my cholesterol has always run about 205 to 220. And I was really excited because I ran my
complete metabolic panel, my cholesterol was down to 115. Sorry, but that's not, that's the
band sign. So, if you have your cholesterol plummet, so if the person wasn't taking lipitor or anything
like that, well, even if you're taking lipitor should plummet 100 points. So, but having low cholesterol
isn't ominous sign. Of course, your 13-year-old cousin who goes and doesn't complete metabolic panel and
maybe they have cholesterol of 115 that can be their normal cholesterol. But if your normal cholesterol
is 180 to 220 or something like that and you go and you run it and it's down in the low 100, that's an
ominous sign of liver cancer. Another ominous sign in the standard blood work would be
depressed or changes in your liver function tests like your alkaline phosphatase, your AST,
your ALP, your albumin, your globulin levels. Those are just different ominous signs. They're not
diagnostic of anything specific without looking at other things, but typically with the thyroid,
a person isn't going to have abnormal thyroid levels and then the person goes, the doctor goes,
well, this could be a sign of cancer, we need to investigate. No, the signs of cancer with the
thyroid will be palpatory findings, would be a mass, would be something we need to do an ultrasound
and then do a scan of and then do a biopsy of. So that's what would be my take on that.